good day folks welcome to episode two of
the triforce i'm peter brown with rob
handlery hi hi hi
uh we're still playing the crap out of
breath of the wild and today turn your
mind up
we everyone my mic was down yeah
uh yes you probably didn't hear me i'm
peter brown's rob hanery we are doing
episode two of the triforce today where
uh basically rob and i just dick around
in breath of the wild uh have fun uh
today is all about mounts horses bears
deer you name it oh my we're gonna try
to ride it
uh yeah um so let me get this started uh
first thing we're gonna do is try to
catch a horse in the wild yeah let's get
real basic here huh
as you can see we already got a this is
porky but porky hasn't been cutting it
lately
sorry bud actually why don't you know
we'll we'll use porky here
yeah horse we'll go find a new horse uh
i'll be paying attention to chat we've
got youtube and twitch up so if you have
any questions for us or suggestions let
us know
yeah uh there is a lot to do with just
you know
just saying you know riding a horse and
mounts you know there there's a plenty
amount of uh fun things that orient
around that idea so
uh we're gonna
i guess later on there might be sorry
bird there might be uh
some spoilers we're gonna uh find
basically these kind of more rare
horses uh some of them have side quests
associated with it uh if you for those
of you who know there's like uh a really
big horse huge horse huge horse that
we're gonna find and capture and so i'm
excited to actually do that because i
haven't really seen much footage or know
anything about doing that yeah so
there's the big horse there's like a
majestic white horse that yeah i think
used to belong to zelda i think so yeah
um you can ride a skeleton horse if
you're at the right place uh tonight you
can ride deer you can ride bears
uh you can even ride a lionel those
big violent
dudes that are really difficult to beat
super difficult yeah you can do it for
uh just a few moments right right uh
before he bucks you off yeah uh where
are the horses at i always figured to be
around here
have you ever had a horse die on you
peter uh only at my own hand
yeah
uh
mike maherty saw me the other day
accidentally killed my horse you seen
horses you should be able to find some
wherever there's a huge clearing you
should be able to find some usually
written by uh
i always figured i saw some right around
here
i say head to your left like where that
sun is
how many horses have you been through at
this point because i i haven't done a
whole lot of the actual taming and you
know raising of stats and all that but
you've been i got pretty into it yeah i
like horses
i got about four two of them are named
charlie uh after my first dog who was
like an old black uh little terrier and
uh i found one with a white mane and
then five seconds later i named him and
then five seconds later i found one with
like all black
mane and skin and i was like all right
well you're actually legitimately
charlie so i have this fake charlie in
my stable the replacement charlie yeah
uh but in general yeah you know it's fun
to find like cause you're kind of dealt
with like two different types of horses
really like strong horses and then fast
horses yeah so you would want you know
ideally like a horse
uh for battle and maybe a horse for just
like you know booking across the fields
here where the do you hear that music do
you know what that music means
what you're getting close to guardians
dude this one
that song means guardians really
that guy yeah yeah come get me
all right
uh let's just get out of here i know of
a better area to find horses if we could
yeah i guess you could go there as well
yes yeah
this is probably the easier
[Laughter]
my horse is left
to fend against himself
uh i remember when you told me that
there are bears in this game and i
thought you were a goddamn liar
you did you thought i was lying i think
well
because i had played so long and i
hadn't seen a bear i played like 70
hours at that point i was like dude
there's no way what do you mean there
are also black bears
i saw one on the mountain once are they
bigger is there a different behavior
like what's the
i couldn't really tell
seem to be just a different skin
oh look at my health real hot
apple
so those durians i found a location that
like um i think i was telling you this
that has a bunch of those oh my god you
just cook those and you're set that's
all you need
so
[Music]
let's get some apps
here some desserts
let's book it let's go find a horse
[Music]
did they hang out in the rain
yeah i think so
they don't care
there we go
all right
so it begins so you can sneak up on them
my favorite technique is to use uh
rivali's gale jump up and then land on
them oh sure yeah i've been hearing the
uh one of the best approaches is to come
from above yes but
uh
ooh no not raining uh wtf wtf rift is
saying get the lord of the mountain we
are going to try it's uh this is like a
a
mythical beast that lives in uh hyrule
that only appears at night and then only
once in a while at night
so uh maybe we can see that i've only
seen it twice in the hundred hours
yeah
yeah eric sneaking behind us i don't
know why
because i didn't do the mics properly oh
weird this horse is running weird
because you're making it run weird
that's right
so yeah you gotta uh oh oh oh
scabs
you know of all the games with horses i
love this one
so much and that you know it's it's
there's effort and there's care involved
in your horse you know you can't just
like throw them into battle
like
i can't you can but you want to like you
know get that that bond max because like
he's resisting he is resisting me right
now
oh look at him he's freaking out and the
other thing i really love is when you
first get your horse
he like won't look at you
[Laughter]
so then when the bond happens you'll see
like eventually he'll like he's always
watching you master where are you
so yeah building the bond you do by
soothing them or petting them but you
can also feed them does that also
bond with them better yeah speaking of
feeding i found something really cool oh
look at that weak bond there
you can see in his eyes he hates me oh
here what should we name him
chat we did this last time
uh
two episodes ago throw your names at us
we'll pick one if you do if you do one
letter
if the chat does one letter and the and
it will just read okay we'll read the
first five or six
all right throw some letters at me i
will take we gotta like alternate
consonants and vowels though last time
it went okay
okay let's see we'll see
no it's gonna come
darkest
all right i'm starting with an o
i like it for historian
x
e
[Laughter]
three more letters k
okay so this is what we're getting this
is gonna be like an aztec name happening
here
oh whoa oh wow oh whoa
uh so
uh let's go
with
ey
all right pronounce that
exit
i'm into it
oh
are you sure
i've never been less sure of anything in
my life
and there you go
uh so show us that little dance you were
doing earlier
oh make your host damn so here's
something real cool is uh obviously you
can this is my favorite oh yeah
eat it
eat it
and then he likes it here's another cool
one i saw this in
the youtube chat in one of our videos
endura carrot if you give this to them
those are the only two things i know of
that you can feed if you look at it now
uh
i have three extra spurs there yeah so
if you know it's kind of like my um
if you've ever heard of that term before
like nope warm emergency power okay so
it's like you know it's just a couple
more
gases
uh and then they will deplete but you
know just in case you never know if a
guardians can sneak up on you and you
have already depleted your given amount
we'll get away there
so anyways that's it
let's
now change it up and uh
so there is a stable
i marked it it is
here
that uh
it's a good stable to go to
why would that be there is uh cool
features you can do there i love
features yeah so we're gonna we're gonna
go there uh let's start off um a little
bit closer and we'll go to this one
um so yeah let's go to stable kind of
kind of show what you can do
like
dressing up your horse
and then uh
and then i think we should start
tackling these rare mounts yeah
the bear we can probably find no problem
deers i don't know where to find i guess
deer is the plural i don't know where to
find deer exactly
like
hyrule
i mean
of course yeah know right yeah but like
i think forests generally even bears are
where i tend to see them
perusing
but um
i forget we need to do a little
exploring first i think i know where we
can find the uh
the skeleton horse i'll have to be
honest
i'll have to be at night but i have a
good area in mind because basically they
appear wherever you find enemies riding
horses not just at
night um is there a horse that has just
the maximum stats
across the board have you seen one like
that
well
yes the only one i've seen is uh i think
it's a pona meaning you have to have the
amiibo
yeah but we're not doing that cheating
cheating cheating um
i don't need your tips right now
but uh
yeah
but i've seen some i think i've seen
pics of like the ones that will i mean
yeah i'm curious to see what the lord of
the mountain his uh horse stats are so
he is apparently incredibly fast like he
is just
i think beyond what a normal uh horse
could
ever be damn yeah
um
yeah i would imagine right because
that's the touching back on the the two
things i was saying was like yeah either
you know generally it's like a fast
horse or a strong horse so i could
imagine the big horse would be that
would be that or a real sexy horse or a
real just sexy horse with a stud
stud muffin and then i wonder what uh
the i'm sorry i'm just checking here i
gotta go a little right
and i wonder what the uh white horses or
if that's like yeah maybe the same case
of opponent oh
oh no bow huh
nope didn't mean to do that
go
a lot of guys around here uh and you
were saying that there are like races
and like archery competitions and stuff
yeah i haven't done any of those either
have you oh no no yeah so there uh yeah
i guess there's a race and there's um an
archery one
[Music]
that uh you can i think you get prizes
hopefully horse prizes type
because you can put gear on your horse
right yeah so you can put a new saddle
and you can kind of like customize can
you customize their main like yeah yeah
you can but that's not like gear that
does the main right there's like gear
for the face but the main is different
right and i think you once you put the
gear on i think your main no matter what
it is it gets kind of uh
you know tucked under yeah so
yeah people look the same this guy
crunch look out
crunch
oh whoa
yeah you're just riding right up to well
i guess it's not the castle type where
am i
oh is this toward the beginning this is
the first central tower it is oh right
yes this is the uh the great plateau
okay right here
uh if you guys are just joining us this
is the triforce myself and rob henry
once a week thursdays at 11 a.m pacific
time
uh just have fun in zelda try to pick a
theme and stick to it but who knows
what's to happen today we are checking
out horses bears skeleton horses deer
mythical deer
bears again just all sorts of stuff all
the different animals you can ride and
what you can do with them
we are paying attention to the youtube
and twitch chat so if you have questions
uh if you have requests uh regarding
what we're doing just let us know and
we'll do our best to accommodate yeah
most death yeah
uh hopefully we're getting pretty close
to the stable
it's funny to think this is so close to
the beginning area and i haven't even
gotten there yet yeah right and because
like once you get
off this area you're kind of like peace
i just want to run right right you don't
think to actually like look around the
base of it yeah you're absolutely right
like there's a mountain with fire on it
i want to go there
so i think i was looking
at tips what is wrong is that a yiga
imposter
get back here
oh you think
[Music]
your blood
oh
[Laughter]
just some nice fish is all
and also
dead ass oh
okay and also
these guys are kind of pushovers
it's intimidating when you first start
to meet them but like
it just takes a few hours afterwards and
you're like oh yeah oh buddy
i've never seen a horse fight for you
really oh i don't even have my freaking
swords out
dang oh i just got this one wind cleaver
that's one way to use it crap i was
thinking of a different sword i'm kind
of losing it uh mr
psy is asking in the youtube chat can
you get a maxed out horse
um without amiibo
not to our knowledge it could very well
be possible we haven't seen one yet yeah
pokemon
oh man i've never seen that spear before
yeah it's gone dude you're cashing in
um oh fireflies
yeah your distractions yeah
yeah your horse will uh
stand up for you it's pretty cool
all right
i think i'm nearing
the stable
oh is it up please don't tell me it's up
there uh
really
but you've got that that super jump
right
no you don't oh i do actually
and climbing gear
oh oh
a blood moon rises once again
i wish they could just skip that whole
cinematic
i mean you can like press buttons to
skip it but i mean just in general i
don't even want to see it start
yeah oh
great was talking adjusting today about
that i wish it didn't make that damn
noise
like it's so far away you can see it and
it's like i know i know there's a shrine
there i'm looking at it i'll put it up
yeah all right i guess it could just
glow
yeah instead of making a sound yeah
there's a i mean there's a prop there
like that's all you need all right so
what what makes this stable so special
well
easy i think that's okay
[Music]
no that's not him i took someone else
out because in order to do the cooler
things with horses
you gotta go do uh candy here
uh you have to have your horse maxed out
as far as your bond gotcha uh right you
need to be real good friends with your
horse
in order to
do this
[Music]
what you got
[Music]
just let her keep clapping
all right so let's let's
customize our [ __ ]
i love that gosh
floral made what it's like what's up
horse here
that's pretty rad
cornrows ah
adorable i think he likes it oh yeah
that'd be great
long green mane
gross ew
been rolling around in the fields
ice
fire
party
cool
weird weird i like the mohawk
so
done
i think i love it
oh so this is uh
some gear i got so yeah i think you know
it depends maybe on the gear but yeah it
might
change your main back to just this
cool
piece uh and that's a fun one i found
what does the monster bridle do
i don't really know oh
yeah uh i would hope that it would have
an effect but i couldn't see
if it did or not um you know i'm
assuming maybe something at night with
monsters but yeah
i don't think so so yeah you can change
your saddle so that's one of the things
we'll do is i think you are awarded
things um
with the races and stuff uh that you do
archery contests we'll see if we can do
one later but i say
we uh
go try to find the lord of the mountain
now wanna do that give it a shot it is
night time
uh yes this lord of the mountain is sort
of like
the hardest mount to find because it
appears randomly and only at night so if
you don't see it you might have to uh
like set up camp
right and keep waiting um the only thing
now as i'm realizing is
in order to come back oh blood blood
moon coming you gotta go to that shrine
yeah i don't know where the shine is
though i guess well maybe if you turn on
that beacon
dang beaten
bacon
yeah i think you're on it
[Music]
this is always man the first time that
happened
oh the blood moon right he was like what
and you look in the sky you're like whoa
pet that dog i should have
have you ever done that given the dog
meat
and he will
lead you somewhere
what
i've like rolled around with the dog
you've never heard of this
you give the dog meat and he'll he'll
take you somewhere yeah he'll show you
like hey thanks for the meat mcguy
come with me he'll show you yeah we're
like treasures and stuff what yeah so i
gave four of these bones he's buried
he just takes a dump
uh perfect
so no yeah uh i did one i gave him like
four pieces of steak and he showed me um
where a star fragment was
dang yeah that's cool yeah that's cool
the first time i saw a star fragment
fall from the sky i was like
if a ufo just crashed
or if i got some like really crazy gear
from it
oh you know it's like okay can you
uncheck
that text there
on the top oh because of the score yeah
i just saw somebody chat that's from no
i kind of like i think i feel pretty
good about it
that was from uh last episode where we
had a little competitive shield surfing
action yeah
okay so we're here so
uh-oh
got him so we need to go
to tory mountain i believe this is it
you don't don't have a shrine you're
there okay
it's right there damn it
well that's fine so let's uh see here
what's that ride not too bad let's do it
all right
uh you're gonna bring out your best boy
yeah i just should bring on my my main
guy
[Music]
bob jones is asking what are the star
fragments good for uh so the gear that
you get from amiibos
you can use them to upgrade at fairy
fountains
to raise their stats and you can cook
with them for like super strong
food or is it only for elixirs
i have i haven't i'm like too afraid to
use the one i have oh really uh but
you're gonna lose it man yeah true
uh you'd lose it but
but i've heard that you need star
fragments for like upgrading pieces of
armor certain types
yeah yeah that's what i was just saying
so the amiibo gear that you get oh
you're saying specifically okay yeah
that's the first stuff i've seen that's
needed start fragments to upgrade i've
maxed out a few things
um and haven't seen that
so that guy
oh this guy is potentially a
representation of the late satoru iwata
um the former head of nintendo who
passed away unfortunately uh about two
years ago
um
and satori mountain is essentially named
after him and
the lord of the mountain is supposed to
be him as well as sort of a lasting
tribute
um
that's really cool it's pretty cool they
put it in there and they find a way to
make it subtle
oh
you got arrows i got rubies
yeah i think it was you said like any
any opportunity to get arrows just do it
just do it yeah
um yeah the other day i had like 100 i
was like i'm good like probably an hour
later it's like out
[Music]
wait doesn't he tell you about the maybe
i've already talked to him
he's a tall man yeah right doesn't he
tell you to go to the top of the
mountain
oh maybe
[Music]
oh he's like doing this come on
yeah yeah come on
faster
faster
he's way down with all that gear
maybe oh no probably not but
oh great
where are you
oh
oh my god screw this
i gotta find i gotta find the lord of
the mountain
uh
abraham
paez is asking the maximum number of
stamina or the maximum like meters you
can have three rings the one you start
out with and you can build two more
around it it takes quite a bunch to get
there
it's worth it yeah i think it's the
first thing you should do yeah just get
out of the way i will say i cashed in a
lot of hearts just to max out my stamina
and i got sort of blindsided because i
got so used to having like 15 hearts
going back to 10 was like
yeah
yeah even the other day when we did a
stream with tay and i did like early
game look and it was like you know down
to three yeah it's so fun or not fun but
like
you gotta completely change the way you
play like
yeah it's tough
it's tough game all right so it's up
there right
um
can you show me the map real quick yes
correct yeah all right
so by now though we should have seen
that blue glow from a distance
which makes me think he's not there
so it's a time of day right uh so we can
it's not just time of day though really
yeah it's not every night
really yeah
i'll bet money
damn
because i looked it up a bunch of places
because i was alright first time i found
him i couldn't catch him i was trying to
research what the deal was and uh yeah
everyone's basically saying like it's at
night but it's not every night ah well
shoot so you can start a fire we can try
to sleep
um okay cause i had i have seen a glow
and stuff right
[Music]
justin is urging us vehemently to go
find the giant horse should we do it
we'll get there let's let's see what
happens let's sleep until night time
once you know i keep forgetting this is
the best way to like write not use flint
[Music]
night night
good night
and that's stream all right now yeah
so yeah big horse white horse
lord horse lord horse uh bear horse bear
horse skeleton horse uh deer horse deer
horse so i think we should move on then
uh
yeah if he's not here we can uh we can
warp back later next time it's night
okay and see what happens so i marked
where i believe the uh
big horse i think it should be yeah it
should be right around there because
that's like the lake of the horse god is
like somewhere around there and i think
it's right that's too far from that so i
believe we go here
to start or should we just go find them
or like do the quest associated with it
because i think that's here uh the quest
might let's do the quest if we can just
get that trigger
you haven't already like started that
have you no i haven't talked to anyone
okay
a horse of course
do you ever watch mr ed on nick at night
when you're kid no
it's a dumb show
is that the show where they heard they
put peanut butter in the horse's mouth
in order to go
look he's talking
his enunciation is impressive
the only thing i love is billy madison
for the dog
speak for yourself [ __ ] credits
all right
let's get a horse again can you ride
those bulls
pretty sure you can't ride bulls
what pretty horns they have
those are cow's numbers
this guy looks
like he's seen some [ __ ]
hey hey hi
give me my horse
charlie too
okay
that name okay what was it
geez historian in the twitch chat is
claiming that they used electricity to
make him talk by shocking him
hey it was like the
50s
yeah right what was that other movie um
it's it's like a two-named like like
lilo and stitch or whatever it's like a
a cat in a dog movie
you don't talk about no
oh lady and the [ __ ] nope
one wanted both dogs
uh someone would know a chat but put
some boots sure no one of those but the
cat they went through like cats
like because there was a river scene
and they went through like uh like four
cats because they kept drowning it's
messed up and it's like a really popular
like children's like animal
jesus yeah this is an old movie
not homer bound it's like a uh
it's two
wait so where's this damn guy oh you
know what i think he's like along the
path is what i think
okay
milo notice
i think that's it
i think that's the one
yeah we got multiple votes
okay so we're following this one
aristocats get out of here
more horses
so do you do you know the rough area
where the giant horse
yes it's apparently where that skull is
oh
foreshadowing but
yeah i yeah it's crazy i've never been
in this like this area over here jesus
so you don't really like horses do you
um
i you and eric are the same way it's one
of those things i like the idea of but
it just
i feel like it slows me down from just
discovering new stuff sure because once
i get a horse and i can ride it it's
like all right like i've kind of
experienced this
so what's left to do right just make it
go faster like bond with it i just i
don't have it in me like that doesn't
make me thrilled in any way
i'm just dead
no you're right i mean i uh
i definitely find myself like
pushing the limits like
you're right where it's like sometimes
you come to that
inevitable roadblock with a horse where
it's like i might as well just start
climbing this mountain
but it's like i'll be like no i wanna
stress test this horse and then he'll
die
too stressful too stressful
uh
yeah okay
okay okay
oh like what's down there you know like
what's over there what's that place's
story i know right well this music just
started playing too which is
the theme from ocarina but yeah
you see the uh easter egg video joey the
original zelda oh i think this is it
oh this is the camp where you can do the
archery stuff oh yes and the soap yeah
awesome
perfect great i love it how are you
where's this horse hi
oh yeah
uh-huh
go on
[Music]
you liar horosconte
[Laughter]
you're so full of [ __ ]
[Music]
a giant horse
oh it was terrible
sure i'll do it
oh yeah taobob grasslands eh
dude i'm taking it like giving it to you
that's like most quests you know it's
like can you find this for me it's like
yeah yeah
i had so i had a quest yesterday
uh i was in terrytown
and the guy's like hey i'm going to give
you down payment to do a quest so he
gives me 100 rupees he's like cool
i need you to go kill these two
guardians in this little forest i was
like sweet so i did it and i came back
and i was like all right the down
payment was 100 rupees
surely the payoff's gonna be great he's
alright cool thanks here's 20 rupees and
he was like what do you expect more no i
guess you don't know what a down payment
is no i gave you the most up front he's
like he's like giving me [ __ ] for
expecting him to pay me
wow
i should have just not done his errand
there was a there was another guy in
that stable he has like the small thin
glasses
and he's always like hey you want like
this rare piece of like
elixir or something yeah it could have
been and it's like bad weed
like legitimately that's what it is it's
he's just like just happy food he'll
just like charge you and then he'll walk
away and he'll like laugh and you just
really just got swindled like it's wow
this game is like
oh and the not forgiving that quest was
called like
it was called like the the hobbies of
the rich so when i came back he was
sitting on a cliff
having watched the area where i was
fighting the guardians so he basically
paid me just to like
fight in front of him and just watch
from a distance while i almost
died because he's rich and he can do
that oh i love it damn it
i missed like half of what this guy just
wanted i think he said what did he say
uh northwest the taubob
something if you zoom in i'm sure you
can see it it's it's probably right
where you thought it was the archery
stuff oh no that's what he was doing i
thought on the big horse yeah let's do
the big horse yeah stay on track this
game is
insane okay uh
he said like over here but yeah okay
yeah
oops so we'll just go
okay up and around this bend yeah
bet you there's a bear in there
i bet you're right what is that what is
that is that a sleeping bear there's
something in the middle
what is that is that modeling what are
you
i don't know what are you oh wait yeah
it's probably because there's lookouts
oh my god we're so distracted all right
let's keep going
that's this game right
shut up
big horse
huge horses
can you do you know if you can uh
you know put him in the stable
yeah i think he can okay you know what i
love is like doing this you ride
backwards 69.
what nothing
look what you've done
oh look at these guys give me a hard
time
yeah let's do this now i'm pissed i
think he was riding a pony that horse
oh no
[Laughter]
charles charles
oh wow
you're a monster dude dude i didn't do
that you just pierced the heart of your
best friend
wow
that was my horse that was my horse oh
no
just can you throw a fair oh whoa can
you throw a ferry on a dead horse
probably not
come here
i'm gonna kill all your friends
yeah what's up
dude i lost him i so so i've always gone
back a save
style points oh where you going where
are you going
dang it how many weapons have you broken
this save so far hey man
materialism
forgot to say well great just grab
there's a that pink horse if you turn
her up the this way
that made me sad
dang yeah gaijin shinobi points out that
there is a fountain to revive horses
which they discovered a couple weeks ago
much to my surprise when i thought it
was going to be a very
creepy
man that makes me sad
because i'm not gonna yeah i'll go back
to the thing he gave his life for the
cause he did
um all right let's
let's move on huh
wow i haven't been here before
these trees are weird-looking
what a weird place see that guy's balls
they were weird-looking
i thought we were doing billy madison i
forgot
when
when he pushes eric over the bench
[Laughter]
[Music]
looks like we got some competition well
one of our challenges was to mount this
guy
all right
i said it
uh yeah so he you can like approach him
without your weapons drawn and he'll
kind of just stand there yeah i tried
that
what is that fantastic dish you've got
going on which one that looks like thai
lime and something skewers you mean
these sneaky fried wild greens yes
that's what i mean
they did nothing to my health no but
that'll be good for the big horse
how stealth so you can sneak up how long
was that six minutes six minutes i got
this too
um
you could just guardian arrow this guy
your ancient era him oh will that
vaporize him it literally just it sends
him through a black hole and he's going
we gotta mount him all right oh right
right that boy
let's do this oh
right let's do it yeah good doggy give
me a sec dude that club is massive
wow i've never seen that club before
yeah look at him he's just like
dan
yeah get out of here
dude you just leveled up
sorry it's one for the books
oh what the heck was that i don't know
what is that weapon
oh my god
that thing is intense
wow
get out get
[Music]
wow i want you to get that weapon so bad
all right let's get it
oh i forgot you can stasis him nice can
you just take his weapon
some enemies don't have much time
oh man i just got rocked all right all
right all right down some durian all
right all right i should have cooked
these damn it not prepared
wow oh jeez
he should really brush his teeth yeah
dude i'd say use oh i'd say use the
ancient arrow but then i think he would
also send his weapon into that black
hole
get that oh yeah i don't want to do that
but
he's got to be susceptible to ice arrows
because if he's got fire elements going
on there we go
okay dude like no damage
wow
what is that
maybe i can loosen him up with one of
those yeah yeah will it kill him like
kill him kill him it'll just suck him
into a black hole
that that's what happened to me
yesterday when i use it on one
god what a
jerk what a real tough customer
uh hey there's a shrine nearby
no ah there we go all right
[Music]
weapon
that is no you're right over that well
the thing is when i put it on i don't
think it's gonna be uh don't burst my
bubble okay
oh gosh
i would try see if you can use an ice
arrow on him because he's he's using all
this fire stuff i feel like he's got to
be weak to ice
you can't prepared
oh
damn it
[Music]
wow
a valiant effort though
should have been prepared
well we didn't expect that i also turned
off all of my powers
should i turn those on
where am i going to start all right hey
this isn't too bad
it's not too shabby there he is though
what a badass
what does he do well this is it this is
his day
hey he hates it just as much as you see
he got the wrong shift i didn't sign up
for this job
all right let's try this again i'm gonna
do it man
uh let's let's add some
oh i gotta cook that damn it
you can't make a fire real quick right
oh but you need a pot to cook it in yeah
all right i can do this
actually i can turn one of these on
should i do it
dude turn them all on
not all of them
you're so proud rob
no not all of them i can do this just
one i just want one little pride and
prejudice
what's up i'm back
it me
suck it
get him horse
[Music]
did you have a stronger weapon other
than the master sword
good call
i know that one doesn't break but
hey at this stage
oh these guys oh that's good that's good
i want my shield up though you could try
right oh i'm
sorry i can get a little flustered
oh that one
in the air
dude just lay into him do you have any
bows that shoot like multiple arrows at
once uh yeah it's one of his buddies it
was like i think it's like five arrows
five arrows yeah i'm pretty sure whoa i
haven't used it yet um
come closer
come hither
dunk him
that's three
yes okay uh yeah let's see that bow
yeah five dude savage
oh man because you know what it does it
still uses just one arrow oh you're
kidding no [ __ ] that's why that's why
it's really good then let's give them
this one
[Laughter]
oh look he loves it
okay now he's pissed
whoa
i wasn't ready
i chose the dodge
ah where are you
with my horse no no no no no no no oh my
god that is horse meat oh wow that is oh
my god no he's all right
brazilian booger
okay what am i doing here uh
yeah
arrow to face
yeah
come
so probably that'll be this savage club
i assume
yeah
wrecking shop
out of those
it's all right
next
yeah yeah yeah the shock doesn't do
anything
oh really
oh this damaged them there was one time
it didn't work i don't know maybe it's
just like you know different elemental
types
oh you've got this
uh everyone who's just joining us this
is the triforce i am peter brown joined
by my friend and co-worker rob hanery uh
he is currently trying to destroy lionel
uh but we are on our way to get the
game's uh giant horse this is zelda
breath of the wild if you don't know uh
there's a
big-ass horse in this game that you can
ride a lot of regular horses some deer a
bear a legendary
god oh wow
um yeah we got distracted along the way
as you do and uh we're gonna take down
this guy real quick cause rob can do it
i believe in him it's personal
uh if you guys have any questions put it
in the chat we are monitoring youtube
and twitch as best we can
oh crap
[Laughter]
should we move on
yeah we should but i know what you're
doing right after the stream i know what
i'm doing if you're not oh i'm i'm
coming back for this guy
nice
damn
rough business
taste says get good
of course
i don't know people are encouraging you
all right
wrecked again that hurts
dude all right i'm adding that on
i've never used that which the uh
oh no oh it's cool yeah yeah have you
seen it have you seen what it does i
think oh yeah the cinematics kind of
show you but no i haven't done it myself
um
all right i can do this search
said very food
man
i'm not going to hold you back man if
you want to go for it we learned we
learned a valuable lesson in the aero
game
so
i'll leave it up to you oh he's doing it
but you need that you need that bow with
them five arrows
it's doing all that in midair
look at this pose
oh yeah
this game is absurd
as this tastes like
this fight even started like no progress
dude you got this
no problemo
that's your bow brakes
you're dude this bow is your dick oh
oh i think he's pissed
nah
he's just flirting
let's change it up here
oh my god i should have done this last
time oh
okay
dude just killing me
oh you're so close you're so
[Laughter]
we're close insane bastard
oh what is it what could it be
oh yeah you get another savage bow
nice
crusher 78
damn
damn oh
wow
look at my god look at this thing
uh
my horse hand come on horse carry me and
my
paint
[Music]
uh let's get back on track all right
sorry sorry sorry okay
damn
no horse
it's all right
you could use your uh ravalli's gale and
jump and fly i think that goes faster
okay
uh rob we're already 50 minutes into the
street christ
um well we gotta find this horse we're
gonna find this horse
it should be up ahead
it should be up ahead
it's gonna repeat everything you say
great hey let's do that spam
this exploit here look at this oh right
this damn exploit
dude i love the chain on this thing
yeah it's so unnecessary
i guess if you got big-ass limo hands it
makes sense but he's just dragging it
around
let's fight
[Music]
oh you're gonna you're gonna see it now
you're gonna see that thing you didn't
do before now
whoa
robert loggia
whoa
god damn it
i can't get around him without a horse
now
yeah you can just put your weapon away
you think as long as you don't have it
in your hand i don't think he'll attack
you he'll like posture up like he's
pissed but he won't do anything
justin says that's just the first line
all right i think
justin are there multiple lynels we have
to fight to get to this big horse is
that the deal
uh okay i was wrong oh no he's he's fine
just don't take out your weapon you took
out your powers
you that's
uh
oh
you think i did it really
how do i do it just hold down jump and
let go once he crouches oh you're
screwed
oh you can do it you can do it
do it now do it now
no i'm trying oh [ __ ] oh i hear you let
go
nice do it let go
catch you on the flip thanks
nice good advice thank you peter
wow
lionel's huh oh a little balloon up
there
where's this damn horse
that's a woofie
[Music]
next to the big horse there just was a
really tiny horse
justin's saying if we don't beat that
second lionel the big horse may
because he's very disobedient may just
run into him
i guess we'll find out
i mean we figured out how to take those
lineups down yeah
wow dang
so okay honestly i would instead of
trying to stamina or sneak up to him or
rather that i would do the jump so you
can parachute down okay uh that's my
reco okay i like the wreck
uh
oh man he is a
big fella uh bench in the chat is saying
how many hours into this game rob i know
you're like 130 or more hours now
probably 150 yeah but you can get to
this
basically right from the start once you
get off the great plateau yeah
all right easy now easy now
he was a good little boy okay
that red mane
soothe it it's gonna take two rings
you got it
come on quit showing off horse yeah yeah
oh
my god
that's a big horse dude
partially wrong
yeah right should you feed him like get
him on your side a little bit
oh my god
all right
let's give him a couple of these and so
the deal is this is probably ganon's
horse
right yeah
oh man
how many horses does he eat
a horse that raised horses for food
have another one
i am your friend you and i are together
now
eat it
all right
question is
how do i get out of here
do i have to go
like where where you don't have to go
back to that lionel i feel like you're
missing a few stables
christ yeah should i go so i wing it
this way to the left uh or should we
like where is satori mountain again is
that way south oh it's up there yeah
it's gonna take too long to get there
maybe head for that forest up north then
we can see if we can find a bear over
there or something or a deer should we
hang on the right here the forest of
spirits yeah hang her right and take a
take a louie okay
yeah
i don't know if that's possible
no i think you should be okay oh
dang you might be right oh man he is
he is a little stiff
okay okay
this horse is so big
is it taller than link like his
obviously his head is but like his back
yep
can you crawl underneath him if you
crouch
no not quite
um
i don't think i can get out of here
without going back the way i came
and you may just have to kill this guy
uh
should we just move on yeah let's just
move on okay uh i'd like for you to kill
this horse first though you want me to
kill it i want you to kill the horse
i want you to see what kind of fight i
want to see what kind of fight it's
going to put up
this is lo this is wrong why i don't
know
you just ran over two birds and laughed
your ass off
yep
birds don't have any brains
all right
then
you just
ah
let's try this
wait i think he likes you
or he wants you to kill him
oh i don't want to kill him what about
so if i kill him then i'll what if i
don't get the horse back
don't don't don't make me do things
all right let's move on yeah
i don't want to kill i want to come back
uh oh boy yeah so um so if you want to
find a bear the one i've heard like
gerudo highlands
um where i found that first bear was
around
uh
it's like here
all right right here maybe go to one of
those towers or shrines
okay
later horse
man i wonder what he would look like
with the
monster gear on you know probably pretty
red
yikes
sell it back to ganon
just gives you back high rolls like that
oh thank you so much that's why i'm so
upset yeah
everyone i'm sorry
jeez
god i've been a real jerk
cool
show horse race
horse race
yeah maybe let's spend a couple minutes
trying to get a bear
wait a second
god damn it that's okay i mean there's a
bunch of woods down there no not right
here i've never seen a bear around here
i picked the wrong thing it's this one
where where
is she trying to get to i don't know
there's some woods like
around here
like along that path or
like
oh no
it was [ __ ] here toto's sashrine
sorry it's here do it no worries
there's so many shrines
okay everyone's getting upset everyone's
a hypocrite i can't kill a horse but
let's just kill every other animal in
this game no problem
come on i mean there's just such i mean
what other animals have bonds
i've bonded with um
wolves
um okay so let's let's go over our
checklist here
bear bale
lord of the mountain
lord of the mountain white horse we have
to do the white horse white horse
board of the mountain might not happen
depending on if it's glowing or not
apparently
[Laughter]
i said no
it said my place
you can ride that thing right yeah dude
show it who's boss
i said no
[Laughter]
oh yeah sure don't kill that thing oh is
that is there a bear right there yep
let's get a photo
it's
nice butt bear butt
the honey ball
i can't believe so many people are
hitting me for
i guess i get it's a horse people love
horses
perfect people love all sorts of animals
yeah
got him
he's real depressed in that shot
oh
oh
what dude should i feed him
he's gonna charge you nice
[Music]
let's get on let's mount this guy come
here
you ever done this in real life
[Music]
come here
come here
what honey
what is he doing there we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's just that easy
what a dope
is he blink ever
bears don't blink did you know that no
that's not true
one of the thousands of facts you've
made up in a few years i've known you
oh look at this
so what's nice is there's a deer right
over here as well so you can mount that
afterwards god i wish there's like yeah
oh you should get a photo of that uh
that monster
oh really yeah i know there's a quest
that asks you to take pictures of
leviathans i don't know if that counts
as a leviathan looks pretty
leviathany yeah the other ones are
bigger just save it yeah got it
thanks for the tip all right where's the
deer at
uh it ran yonder towards the river
where its husband knocked you into the
water
man i wanted that guy yes
oh great
rob take him down with your bare hands
i can barely stand this oh my god
yikes
how unbearable
the only problem with like
the wildlife
is how quickly they can
with the small ones yeah the the big
guys i feel like he was just over the
hill and you like kind of barely saw him
before he turned around
barely saw him oh jesus yeah
f
what's that this little cave up there
what are you all about mr rock
hell no that's a precarious rock that is
absolutely something in there
but we're not gonna get distracted dang
it
[Music]
nice deer
no venison for us
i think we should maybe leave and come
back divali's gayle is now ready
thank you um
that guy is such a dick
hey do you want to mount us we're cool
too
we're good for your back
okay maybe i come back in
now uh
man they peace out
yeah i think i think once they saw me
riding the bear they kind of figured out
what my goals were oh my god damn i hate
these guys
you can just attack him
oh sure kill the octa rock
you monster let it go peter
no all right i don't know if this is
gonna happen
i think we should move on let's move on
we need to find
uh
let's do the white horse
yeah okay let's do it let's do it
uh i marked it
uh
so is the stable we went to what was it
called um
this was it
yeah outskirt i believe this is where
the
quest lies for the white horse
uh so maybe after this we can try
because the lord we can try to find the
lord of the mountain if we get to time
it's probably not going to happen but we
can at least do the archery stuff
the horse racing yeah the horse racing
and yeah yeah
i believe the horse racing is at this
stable as well
i believe okay
what would this feel like
i'm gonna turn this off like reverse
diarrhea yeah
uh yeah i don't like this one okay
our volley's gail is now ready
coming in
drop three two one
[Music]
all right let's [ __ ] this guy
weird
welcome
you sound tired
is that obvious
oh this guy's
oh
sounds rough
hmm
oh is this the guy that asks for yeah he
like asked for
increasingly expensive and rare cuts of
meat okay well that's not our guy yeah
worry about him later
hi
i know how to cook
pure white horse
wink wink
[Laughter]
only 500 rupees
grazing on
sapphire hill
yeah we get that
oh
give me back my white horse
no
i'm not this is another one of these
things like okay yeah i'll give it back
to you idiot
all right on to safula hill we go
let's check our map
uh console hot is saying there's a lot
of creeps in this game and i inclined to
agree i am a lot of jerks a lot of
creeps
did i tell you the uh
the one the other day i heard or saw on
the internet was like um during a blood
moon there's this one guy i think at
like dueling peaks who just circles
as it's happening he just circles the
stable and he's like all of his um text
subtitles are red and he's just like
arise monsters like he like gets a kick
out of uh blood moon yeah wow
yeah so he's a creep uh venereal in the
twitch chat is asking if you can show
your armor
like loadouts and stuff
um let's take this one out since chat
made this horse
okie yeah i can do that okay okay
what was it okay
i don't know
i mean should i show my stuff
yeah why not
look away for five seconds if you don't
want to see you don't want to see warmer
cool armor look away
all right here's one stuff i think or
maybe you just wanted to see the gear
you were wearing also that hat
so cool
uh yeah this is just the standard uh
hylian fit that's um
painted black dyed black here's the rock
climbing fit this fit is a must
climb way faster
i got some of this
and then
there's bees
made a weird noise yeah so that's when
it's you know when the set is activated
uh uh my speed at night is faster and i
was showing the other matt that's been
all the other day like uh this plus uh
speed boost
yeah oh oh my god yes you don't need a
horse ever like you're so fast
uh anyways
so if you guys were looking away you can
look back now we're back to normal yes
all right let's go get this
that dude is obsessed with horses his
name is trot
oh that's right this uh this is a newbie
horse here
chill out
someone talked to my cat from now on
when it's doing the wrong thing
oh
oh
birdie
oh man he is
resisting stop resisting
mark cochran's asking have you tried to
ride a horse or uh sorry a goat yet
can't do a goat can't do a goat it's
just you know the the two are uh yeah
bear
and uh deer horses deer it's a shame you
couldn't ride a moose
yeah yeah
chill shame you can't get piggyback
rides from strangers
yeah
there should be a guy that gives you
piggyback rides in this game that would
be freaking awesome
or at least maybe like a like a side
quest where you you have to like
give an old man right across like the
whole entire map
jesus
jesus is right
chill out
all right
nope nope you gotta turn around
onward ho
we're looking for a white horse so i
think you're going to run into some
enemies on horseback here so prepare
yourself steal yourself
me and old oxy
oxykini ask oxy kiki to eat
we got this
all right
i think it's i think you're veering off
track oh really i think it's down in
this big section here oh really that's
what i believe yeah well said hill
i'm already uh okay
[Music]
oh it's crazy so like one of the
memories is right there right um and
just like
didn't see that horse when i was over
here last time
crazy
all right
i guess that makes sense why would be
near a horse statue kitty akashi in the
youtube chat says did the ige clan quest
and now the yiga appear way more often
and you kind of easily die they appear
frequently after that quest yeah and
they're not disguising themselves right
as often the the sort of big brutes with
the big swords are a little bit tricky
uh but they're not as punishing as they
are inside of the yiga headquarters
at least in my experience
there she blows
oh you should
what up
should i what i was gonna say ride your
shield down there and hop off
your shield but there's not really a
good enough jump i or speed i don't
think i'd be able to get back up the
hill
all right let's get to it
hello
should i put on my stealth gear uh yeah
maybe
what
someone's talking about our horses good
old uh good old oxycontin
all right lord
look at this
look at this right here what a classic
little shot here
what are you doing what are you looking
at what's your story
[Music]
yeah yeah
all right let's bring her on back huh
check out these stats on the horse
or stats
my gear back on
so
let's do uh
oh is this
that's satori mountain right
yeah it is
no
it is
what
satorium yeah to the right
oh but to your far right
okay i was just curious like it's
nighttime i guess yeah we we would see
the glow by by now at least
oh wow look at this speed five yeah
that's fast
i like it
i'll take it she rides pretty well
have you heard uh i was saying it
earlier the easter egg video we did
where um some of the songs you speed up
are like right zelda or classic zelda
songs yeah speed it up like five times
it's crazy and a little weird yeah like
you wouldn't
you would never notice it
this might be my new horse what should i
name it
dang vanilla vanilla
that's weak
put your requests in the chat crunchy
taco crunchy taco come on
all right gordita crunch come
on what's he yelling at
uh
let's see it's gotta be something where
i i mean
the chat isn't gonna be any better i
imagined
crunchy taco i mean it's gotta be
something resembling
why
because
butter i like butter butter's good
butter is actually really good
[Music]
hey old man this is what you're looking
for
vanilla ice is one
eminem
blanche
a blanche
on francais
oh that's that's good it's good stuff
buttermilk all right
mars
lord nila
white dorito
all right peter of these
ranch dressing nilla is good
nella's good lord cream
[Laughter]
caucasian no no
um talk to the old dude oh i get fancy
gear butterfinger
all right cracker no
buttercup butter i like butter butter
dorito
two d's
let's it with butter
yeah why not do we really even care that
much no i care
butter's good butter's good
butter is good
or should we should we do something like
booty so when i that joey did so when i
call for it oh booty it seems booty
could not hear your call yeah
yeah screw it it takes too much time on
it butter it is ah
say you will get the royal attack
okay
oxenfree
butt station no butt stallion butt
station
that's like that's like a band name too
all right buddy give me my gear
ooh little cinematic
oh
you just made his life dude
damn
he just dies
he's like i can die now
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh
[Laughter]
who's going to react to people like that
in real life i would love it not even to
say words they should understand what
i'm getting at by my noises
uh all right so we're going to take this
horse into a race i think so alrighty um
i want to feed it just because
he deserves it
yep another
that horse has been alive for a hundred
years
oh you know what you do
put some braids on it flowers
yeah
yeah
yeah
oh
oh
the horse doesn't like me enough i just
realized that
come on don't
hope she can't tell
we're good friends meeting this horse
she's being real passive-aggressive with
you
with threatener like if you don't give
me what i want i'm gonna hurt this horse
i have 12 swords on me
magic bombs
14 bows and arrows listen lady
i'm like the hero
oh now you're gonna shoot the horse i'm
not
a kid a kid
horses are a very touchy subject peter
all right uh the race i think it's here
shoot
is the race here
well if you go back to the place where
you've kicked off with the giant horse
thing where you talked to that guy he
had the archery
test okay the horse the horseback
archery test all right um
that would be
that was down this way right
uh back
so i warp here it was like sort of
around the bend coming from the stable
right it was uh okay so it wasn't it
wasn't too bad yeah
oh this episode should have been called
the try horse
good one philanthropy thank you
try horse
dang it
we blew it
we suck again well we've done
pretty much what we wanted we've done a
lot yeah the only things we weren't able
to do were find uh lord of the mountain
and mount a deer or a skeleton horse but
man by and large we've kind of yeah yeah
i was actually a little surprised
and that's with
lionel battles and other distractions
yeah
so you had to leave this stable and sort
of like ride the trail get yourself a
horse
okay
give me butter
man i lost that horse charlie i have to
go back and get him
poor guy some horse heaven right now
livid he's gonna be so pissed when you
bring him back so pissed
all right
i love this fit
looking real good all right so it was uh
this way
yeah
dang five is uh this is a well-rounded
horse
i wonder if you fed it a
a not a is it swift carrot yeah carrot
or swift carrot a swift carrot would be
speed i wonder if it could it would run
faster yeah we're having swift carrots
we could try
uh indira
yeah yeah
let's try
no not right now
all right so let's judge the speed here
okay yeah seven out of seven out of fast
sure
have this run fast dine upon my goods
there you go
i don't think so
i feel like it would say right it would
say the buff in the top left or
something yeah
oh
obey me
yeah so apparently uh this is the
archery one are you sure it's here
yes that's what the guy was saying i
guess when i wasn't paying attention uh
well it's literally called the horse
archery camp or something like that
gotcha i think if you pull up on your
map you can probably find the exact
location yeah mounted archery camp okay
we'll
follow uh we are going to be probably
wrapping up after this i think uh so
thank you guys who have all tuned in uh
for anyone just joining us this is the
triforce rob and i get together every
week every thursday at 11 a.m
uh and just sort of have fun in breath
of the wild we try to pick a theme as
you saw today with the lionel battles
sometimes you find some cool stuff along
the way and yeah
you know you stop and smell the roses as
it were
uh so we are going to
do some horseback archery stuff and call
it a day
but uh if you guys have any questions
for us in the meantime let us know i'm
monitoring twitch and youtube chats
i guess i'll wait till morning or do i
go further on
um
these guys are beat yeah wait until
morning
nope whatever whatever whatever
same thing that's when i get up
oh great hey there do your worst rain
um this guy
yeah
yeah
drill yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
oh i think you have to
you have to be on a horse when you talk
to him
gotcha
get over here link i got it
oh
oh
let's do it
i'm fine thanks
the snark and some of the responses link
has is always great like
sometimes they resonate real real well
with a shady character
20 bucks
what's he talking about drills you know
like sports drills oh sure you know
they meant like power tools
oh
good wants to know how much can i get
out of this game in 10 days what is that
i mean you could get out as much as
you're willing to put into it i mean i
think you can play this game for 200
hours i genuinely believe that yeah yeah
uh you can get a lot out of it let's put
it that way does the master sword break
says elijah munga in the youtube chat
uh no it'll run out of power and it'll
take about 10 minutes for it to regain
its power
oh wow he really asked for that that's
all caps yeah
um
yeah you won't be able to use it until
it's recharged i think it takes 10
minutes
yes oh
oh good
party
rock
let's get [ __ ] off dude do it
okay
sorry i didn't want fire arrows
dang it whoa that's good that increases
your chances
bugger
f
i'll get those two i like the way those
balloons are looking at you
really yeah yeah
nice
[Music]
not too shaby
sorry it's so loud i apologize
oh come on you've got two now remember
you picked one up from the lionel
great
no you gotta go to the pause me oh no
you don't
wow
yeah i'll try
let me let me uh prepare this controller
for he's degreasing the controller for
me that's not true it's not it's no it's
just
you're a known liar yeah
put on my seeing goggles for this
yeah i'm good
man i wonder if that bow is now broken
or if it's going to be back here
what
check to see if you have it oh
um
[Music]
so i guess this one's just more like a
the the prize is just rubies right is
the race maybe where you get the gear
uh like one of these offer that that uh
like the race does definitely i'd be
shocked if you didn't get something
beyond rupees is that what he said
though he'll just give you i'm assuming
this one just feels to be that like
like it's a similar it's similar in the
vein of like like uh there's the bowling
one where it's like if you perform well
you get
depending on how well you perform you
get more money um that's what i believe
yeah this is tough
you know i'll be honest though is the
horse
is definitely resistant oh yeah it's not
cooperating right
[ __ ]
i do that all the damn time man it's the
button layout all right rob 11 pete one
uh i'm gonna let you try again okay all
right again
uh how do you get elemental weapons says
uh dino tom uh there's a bunch of ways
there's a bunch of ways there is one
place in particular west of hyrule
castle
a circular location that has a lot of
enemies that carry elemental weapons
so look on your map circle it's not west
of the
wait yeah
you're talking about the coliseum yes
shoot that's right there's something
else in this in the south though i
thought i don't mind probably
um
[Music]
yeah switch to the lionel bow if we
haven't see if i yeah
man that's so cool i didn't know
when i saw the five arrow thing i was
like damn i don't want to do that waste
five arrows at a time i know that's what
yeah i thought so first two but
nice oh it's three
huh that's the one i picked up from that
last jerk
alright you guys
nice
yeah
yep
nice
uh-huh oh
no
nice
i don't like this
you're too good stop
oh double
[Music]
when i was sprinting it made it worse
on the horse
yeah but i think i only have so much
time and i've got to get to the blue oh
sure
nice
cute
all right one more and you get
i hope you missed
all right that's going to do it for
today yeah thank you everyone for
joining us uh this has been the triforce
episode two horsing around another junk
uh yeah i'm at twitter at pc brown you
are robert hanlory
twitter twitter we have lots of other
zelda stuff on gamespot and on youtube
so search for that there
and uh have a wonderful weekend i'm
going on vacation nice i'm going to
tahoe sick uh all right thank you
everyone see you next time see you guys
you